some breaking news for Hunter Biden's
legal battle special counsel David Weiss
telling the judge in charge of the first
son's case that he plans to indict
Hunter before September 29th on that
felony gun charge it comes six weeks
after the implosion of the original
sweetheart plea deal that was meant to
save the first son from going to prison
and while Hunter's legal problems Mount
some of the liberal press seem to be
looking the other way Washington Post
National columnist Philip bumps snapping
and walking out of an interview after
getting pressed on this 2018 Hunter text
message
what do you take from the text message
to his adult daughter uh 100
Technologies I had to get 50 of my
income to pop I have no idea what that
means I don't I have no idea what that
means well it's it's it's I know it's
circumstantial evidence and you prefer
that what what I have no idea I
appreciate your has anybody has anybody
asked her I don't know I don't know
that's why I have nothing to say about
it yeah but you say there's no evidence
no evidence but then there's a text
message where he says I give pop 50 of
my money that's that's evidence okay
well what okay fine fine so evidence
Phil you want me to leave like just walk
out in the middle of this because that
way you can go is this a standard really
this is the way the Washington Post
handles people who disagree with when I
agree to be on for 45 minutes and then I
get on for an hour and 15 yeah then
after a while I go we're gonna get to
the legal thing in a minute but having
to watch that again Greg I have to say I
can understand walking out of an
interview if you were insulted or if you
were disrespected but not because you
were presented with a fact not because
you were getting your butt royally
kicked that was like Mike Tyson you know
pummeling a koala baby but uh and I
don't endorse that I think the thing
that was so what you saw there uh gnome
was amazing in that was the ultimate
arrogance of an elite journalist in
Philip bump how dare you ask me I'm a
journalist how dare you ask me for facts
how dare you expect me to justify my
lazy reporting you know this guy's been
on journalism welfare for years he's
been wrong on a lot of stuff more than
Homer Simpson's gotten wrong and the
Dems have fallen into this excuse I'll
use a Jesse analogy you know sure I go
to a strip club but I don't cheat that's
how they talk about Hunter like Hunter's
bad but Trump is worse and they've been
doing this for years now the fact is
like remember with Sam Harris do
remember what he said remember he
remember he said that if Hunter Thompson
if Hunter literally had murdered
children in his basement he wouldn't
care because Trump is worse and so what
you're seeing there is another admission
of derangement that they cannot admit
they cannot bump is so wrong he had
nowhere to go except to leave it's quite
humorous it also shows Jesse that this
question really hasn't been presented
outside of conservative media so you
have to have
I guess muscle tone if you are going to
go up against someone with an opposing
ideology like we have Jessica we have
Harold so we have to fight over facts
though I mean I have to go up against
people that ask me about January 6 that
asked me about all of the Trump trials I
have to defend everything
these people like bump they don't have
to do anything and they've never even
been presented with a challenge so they
get up there and it's like they just
they're limp you know it's like you know
you go into a you Spar at a gym you've
never sparred before you can't go five
rounds can't even go half a round that's
what happens he's not politically
athletic enough and he doesn't have the
chops to answer
the Smoking Gun document that's one of
the biggest Smoking Gun documents that
we've seen from the laptop the laptop
which has been authenticated by his boss
at the Washington Post this guy's
supposed to be one of the top
journalists at the post and he has no
idea and honestly he doesn't even care
has anybody asked about that I don't
know well I don't know what are you
asking me for oh I don't know because
it's your job to ask the question I it
gives me life I've watched it 17 times
yes
how it felt it felt
is your lawyer and Friends
judge I do want to comment on the Philip
bum interview or the indictment that
could be coming before September 29th
well what I think first of all I got a
copy of the decision from the court uh
it really is a status report and uh they
say uh that given this the request or
the attempt to guarantee a speedy trial
that anything that's going to be filed
has to be filed by September 29th and
now the United States Attorney special
counsel David Weiss apparently is
indicating he will indict Hunter Biden
by September 29th so the question is
what is it going to die tomorrow all
indications are they going to indict him
on the gun charge here's a problem all
right and this is just me talking
the the possibility of indicting Monica
in charge which I think is appropriate
took him five years to get to a plea
agreement and now they can indict him in
30 days what does that tell you about uh
the legitimacy of David Weiss and his
investigation but more important is the
fact that there is a diversion agreement
between the United States Attorney and
Hunter Biden's lawyer I think it's Abby
Lowell and I've said before they don't
get any smarter than Abby Lowell as a
prosecutor if I have a diversion
agreement with a defendant and a defense
attorney it's between me and the defense
attorney if I have a plea deal I need
the Court's permission but as a
diversion agreement it's me and the
defendant saying we're going to work
this out I guarantee we're going to see
legal argument on whether or not if and
when that indictment comes out that
indictment can in fact supersede the
diversion agreement I'm not so sure that
it can because you don't need the
Court's approval to enter a diversion
agreement and they already acted upon it
and in fact the filed with the court
that indeed we have been complying with
the conditions of the diversion
agreement of the gun charge don't get me
wrong the guy should have been indicted
five years ago as quickly as they can do
it now but I think they're in a little
bit of legal hot water here what happens
or what changes Harold
if there is an indictment of Hunter
Biden on a gun charge
I think an indictment on any charge is
is serious first of all let me let me I
think the Judge what she just said I
think is really really important to
amplify uh the diversion agreement uh
Abby Lowell has already indicated that
that's going to be an offer of defense
that he will put forward uh very soon I
I've assuming a public proceeding it
leads me to believe judge that there
might be something else yeah that this
could be either new charge a new gun
charge or some other new charges because
I I don't know how you get around the
judge explained it succinctly and
compelling I don't know how you get
around that yeah it would seem to me to
be foolish to off to bring a set of
Charters you know the judge would say
you can't do because you hadn't you have
this agreement now let me just say a
couple other things first uh I've always
said if President Biden if there is two
questions if they're if he uses official
office to help his son
and or receive benefit for something
that his son was doing that's a problem
and I think a lot of Democrats
Republicans Independents alike would
would say so
um two this guy Philip bump he behaved
like a partisan politician in this in
this interview uh I'm a believer that we
have to have uh journalists on all sides
ask very very tough questions but when
you're asked the question as a
journalist that upends a theory that you
may have been promoting you can't walk
out a politician can walk out but a
journalist can't walk out so it was
disappointing and disturbing disturbing
to see that I know that Mr Comer and
others in the Congress are asking for I
believe Mr Weiss and others that come
before the committee and come and
testifies to what happened I hope they
can show a little restraint because we
are finding ourselves I think closer and
closer to finding out exactly what's
happened and if indeed legal charges
should be brought I think the politics
in it will do nothing but aggravate both
sides and make it more difficult to get
to the bottom of this I'm interested in
the truth here and if the truth is
uncomfortable for me and my party so be
it if it's not so be it we can't get
there unless we have the justice
department and others doing this but it
is the polit ICS that has brought
not the justice department it was the
judge today
in this case it was the judge but all of
the information we're getting about the
failure to interrogate Hunter Biden
because he got a heads up all this stuff
about Kate benningfield giving answers
to Eric schwerman uh for an interview
with the New York Times we're not just
talking about uh uh favoritism we're
talking about collusion between the
White House and Hunter Biden and his
partner that's not about the rest of it
but I don't disappear but it was just
the judicial branch that did this when
they call when those two parties came
before them and said you guys do not
have a meaning of the minds on what this
agreement is about that's what exploded
all so why did David Weiss do it
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now